Hi everybody, my name is Mark, I'm a web developer here, a .NET developer in the web team here
at Portswigger. The web team is responsible for our public website but also for a whole
kind of suite of applications and tools that we use internally to power and grow the business.
What that means is that unlike my colleagues who build Burp Suite and that family of tools,
I'm not a security specialist by trade, my background is in .NET web-based development.
So I've typically worked on teams where application security is a separate function
that happens downstream of my team, usually kind of side by side with the QA function.
So I was really interested to give Dastardly a go, tried to integrate it into my continuous
integration and deployment pipeline and quite excited by the thought of that then being able to
fail my build if a vulnerability is found in exactly the same way I would expect the build to fail if
a unit test or an integration test fails. So what I've got to show you today is a very simple website
with a deliberate vulnerability in it. It's hosted on GitHub and it uses a GitHub Actions workflow to
build the site, run the tests, deploy the site to Azure and finally run a Dastardly scan on that site.
So first thing I'll do is show you the, we'll go to the app code in GitHub. This is a public repo if
anyone's interested in looking at it in more detail, passing a link to their developers or forking the
repo then it's all of that is available. I'm just going to start by making a simple code change because
that will trigger a build and then we can see that that build pipeline in action. So I'm just going to
make a simple change here to the readme file. Save that. And if I now switch to the Actions tab in GitHub,
we should see that that's queued up a build and there it has. So we've got a build at the top there
queued that'll take a couple of minutes to run. So in the meantime, while that's busy, what I'm going to
do is show you the site and demonstrate the vulnerability to you so you can all kind of get
a clear idea of what we're looking to detect and then we'll come back here and look at the code that
had to be written in order to integrate dastardly into that pipeline. And even if you're not a developer
or a coder, I promise you we're not diving into anything too detailed. So here's the site. As I
mentioned, it's very simple and there's a bit of explanatory text on there to say that it's vulnerable
to cross site scripting or XSS attacks. So the way it works is if we type a message in the box here and
click submit, then as long as the demo gods are smiling on us, that message will get added to the
bottom of the screen. But it's being added as raw HTML. So if we were to paste in some JavaScript
into that box and see what happens, you'll see that that's our vulnerability in action. We've just added
JavaScript to the page, the browser has run it and it's triggered a print event on the page. You can
easily imagine that being used to steal customer login details or anything of that kind. So that's
exactly the kind of thing that we're going to hope dastardly can find with its DAS scanning capabilities.
So let's switch back over to GitHub. Our build is still running. If I switch back to the the code view,
you'll see a folder here called GitHub workflows. This is where we build our GitHub actions pipeline.
And it's actually just a single file. It's pretty easy to follow, easy to read. We've got three main
sections in this file that are referred to in GitHub actions as jobs. The first job, which is up at the
top here. That job is going to build the latest version of the code, test it, and then package it up
ready for uploading to Azure. And that's pretty straightforward. The second step here goes from
there to there. And this takes that packaged website that we just built and uploads it to a web app on
Azure. Just worth noting that this is publishing directly to a production environment because we're
just using a free web app on Azure for this demo purpose. So it doesn't have different deployment
environments in a real world situation. This would be publishing to a beta or a staging environment and
running tests there running running vastardly there before the site goes live. But again, we're just
keeping things pretty simple for this demo. But the real kind of meat in the sandwich, the bit that we're
really interested in looking at is this third job that's been added at the bottom. And this is what
triggers a scan with dastardly. And although that's only what kind of 17 lines of code, in fact, it's
simpler than it looks. The bit that makes dastardly happen is just those four lines in the middle. And
we can see there that's grabbing the dastardly action from the GitHub marketplace. So that's a reusable
kind of package that makes it really easy to integrate dastardly into your build. And it's calling
it and all it's providing it with is one piece of information, which is the URL of the website that we
want to scan. Okay. Below that is a kind of optional section, but the documentation for dastardly
recommends adding this and it is really useful, as we'll see later on. What this is doing is just
taking the output from dastardly where it documents its findings and presenting them to us in a more
user readable, you know, user friendly format. So it's well worth having that as well. But it's not
really a core part of getting dastardly into the into the pipeline. So that is it. Literally those last
few lines in the file were all that needed to change in this project in order to integrate dastardly. So
there's nothing to download. There's nothing to install. Best of all, as, as you know, my colleagues
have mentioned already, there's nothing to pay for. There's really no kind of barrier to entry with
dastardly. You can just integrate and go. Anyway, that's enough time spent looking at code. If we switch
back to our pipeline screen, we can see that that that latest build is now completed and it's failed.
And it's interesting looking here at the build history. We can see when I first built this project,
the build pipeline simply ran the build and test step and everything was green gave us a green light
towards the project was fine. Likewise, extended it then to deploy it to Azure and that all worked fine.
And for many web developers, really, this is about as far as their development pipeline goes. And so far,
everything's looking good, right? It's giving us green lights all the way. But as soon as we've added
that dastardly scan for the pipeline, that's when the build starts failing, as you can see here in these
last two steps. So let's click in and look at that in a bit more detail. And what this screen is showing us is
the kind of status of our latest build. We've got a graphical view in the middle there of what
happened when our pipeline ran. And as we just mentioned, you can see the three, those three
sections of the of the configuration file mapped to these three steps of the build. Build and test is
good. Deployment to Azure is good. But the dastardly scan is where our problems happened. It's already
giving us a little heads up down below here that it found cross site scripting vulnerability. We can
click on the scan with dastardly step, drill into a bit more information there. And apart from some
absolutely elite ASCII at the top there, which we're all very proud of, and we wear on our T-shirts,
it does tell us down at the bottom here in fairly brief detail that it found an error. It tells us
where the error code and what type it was, and also the severity, which is judged to be high. I think
we'd agree with that. That's the kind of raw output from dastardly. But that third or that final little
optional section of the configuration that I've pointed out to you before gives us this fourth step
of the build down the left to the dastardly scan report. So click on that. You can see at a glance
the same kind of information presented in a bit more of a graphically appealing way. It tells us the
vulnerability that we found and where it found it. But for me as a non-specialist web developer,
the real kind of juice comes into it when I click raw output and start to look at this. And what
dastardly has given us here now is not just telling us there's a vulnerability on this page of the site,
but it's giving us a whole load of information here about the detail of what this issue is,
which I as the developer may not be really familiar with. Background of the issue, suggested steps to
remediate it. It's fantastic. You get this similar kind of information to what you would find on our
web security academy on the website, but here it's presented right in the build. And I'd really like
to think that it's going to do a great job of educating web developers and making us all kind of
better more app sec aware developers.
So, let's see.
Let's see.